she had been diagnosed with panic
disorder she wasn't taking her
medication she was out of town
and she had called the police on this
particular day march 5th 2015 and she'd
asked them to come to the house i was
i'd actually taken the afternoon off i
was at home with my sons playing in the
playroom with them
and she asked them to come to the house
and said that i was confused and the
dispatch said we can't go to the house
if he's confused she said well what do
you need to hear and they said we need
to hear he's a threat to himself or the
children and then allegedly sometime
later i think 45 seconds later
she she called them back and said
she said my husband's just told me quote
i'm sick of this [ __ ] i'm gonna harm the
children
end quote
and those 10 words that 10 word lie was
was the basis of
law enforcement coming first it was two
to my front door then it was three then
it was five and a sergeant and the
massing garrison uh the threshold of my
home
um without cause without a warrant
[Music]
hello everyone i'm here today with mr
greg ellis a best-selling author tv
director annie award nominated voice
artist and emmy award nominated actor
he's appeared in oscar winning movies
directed hollywood superstars produced
and written television shows starred in
broadway musicals and voiced animated
characters for movies television series
cartoons and more than 120 video games
his major motion picture film credits
include the pirates of the caribbean
series titanic star trek mr and mrs
smith and beowulf
his television credits include 24
x-files csi dexter ncis and hawaii 5-0
with his production company monkey toes
mr ellis has written and directed
projects for kiefer sutherland and
stephen fry who's been on this podcast
he's also the host of several popular
video podcasts and he additionally
founded the child advocacy advocacy
program the respondent which inspires
family champions through his non-profit
cpu
children and parents united his book
which we're going to concentrate on
today at least to some degree is the
respondent
exposing the cartel of family law it's a
call to action
and a necessary one to reform the one
branch of our legal system that does not
provide the presumption of innocence
family law
yeah well that's quite a claim that that
branch of family law that branch of law
does not provide the presumption of
innocence so maybe we could start by
exactly what you mean by that and why
you would make that claim
well uh yeah through personal experience
first of all thank you for having me on
jordan it's great to be on your show
i've been looking forward to this for a
while
um yeah family law the uh the only
branch of our legal system where there's
no presumption of innocence uh murderers
rapists terrorists paedophiles all get
more legal rights than law-abiding
citizens and this the silver bullet as i
call it the silver bullet playbook or
paradigm of high conflict divorce the
smoking gun of this corrupt legal system
um that's become the go-to strategy for
divorce lawyers that guarantees victory
and they encourage
the the petitioners and the respondents
to use usually petitioners to utilize
this strategy usually the false
allegation of domestic violence um to
win in court court to get the uh the
cash and prizes for want of a better
phrase
um and you know when i when i i had no
idea of the words family law before uh
what happened to me happened to me in
2015
um and once i started investigating
through experience and through talking
with other experts
in the system outside the system uh it
became clear to me that that we we have
a real issue here and if we can improve
or reform the family court or the family
law system expose the cartel of family
law as i call it because it is like a
crime syndicate these quasi-kangaroo
courts that they have um you don't get
the presumption of innocence you don't
get your rights read to you uh i've
spoken with fathers in particular who've
been in who've been ended up in court uh
with false allegations of domestic
violence one one told me a story about
he put his wrists up and said your honor
arrest me have the bailiff arrest me and
the judge said are you crazy
and the gentleman said no if i'm
arrested i'll get the rights that a
criminal has miranda rights access to an
attorney et cetera et cetera and of
course those who are suffering the most
are the people who don't have the
wherewithal the financial resources to
be able to have representation and even
those who do if you are the respondent
you are behind the curve it is uh the
the
the the presumption is that you as the
accused have to prove your innocence
rather than the accused which is western
jurisprudence has to prove their case um
and so i think it seems like in our
society in a lot of strange ways
the accuser now seems to have
almost an untrembled right to be
believed
and there's an increasing insistence on
that in our culture as well which is for
example there was a this is a bit far
afield but german chemistry journal the
other day scientific journal published
their new guidelines for authors in the
aftermath of
a scandalous chemistry paper they
published which hypothetically
offended some people
that now authors have to be
what would you say governed by the
realization that their words will be
interpreted by those who read them and
that they have the final say those who
read them
and so on on line two you can be
accused of virtually anything and then
mobbed for view virtually anything and
it's virtually impossible to defend
yourself and
this notion that
merely because someone says they've been
offended
let's say in the mildest of cases that
that means you have definitively done
something wrong is well there's a
pervasive
and broad scale move in that direction
in our culture so
what happened
in your case you were the respondent in
a divorce case which you didn't see
coming is that is that's correct i read
your book it was a while back so i'm
pulling all the bits of it back into my
memory but
let's go through the story exactly and
sure and just just very briefly to that
point yes victimhood has become the new
social currency its economy is booming
and where victimhood is rewarded
responsibility never follows so it's
part of the reason i call the book the
respondent it's the defendant in a
family law case and the um the
petitioner is that person who actually
instigates the proceedings so
um you know what happened to me in the
span of i'd say around eight hours
i'd been married for 20 years two
children two boys
them the meaning of my life
we did everything together i was that
engaged loving present father family was
my everything
how old were your boys at that point
ten years old and eight years old at the
time okay and you said you've had quite
a stellar career and and obviously we're
very busy doing that so in what sense
was your family at the center of your
life
that's a great question yeah i think
my my now ex-wife and i were we drifted
somewhat to become a well-oiled marriage
machine um the avoidant in her and the
anxious in me couldn't quite
get close enough i think uh pia melody
calls it the co-addicted love tango
where we were kind of swaying back and
forth trying to get closer but drifting
apart i would be out of town filming a
movie and return and she go out of town
because she wanted to work and i
supported that i would have preferred
she stayed home but she wanted to work
so i was like great so we worked our
schedules out
that we could be present and much of my
work was was in town in hollywood um
at one of the studios
so you know
i had a busy career and but my i would
still say as you did that my family was
the center of my life if i had to choose
existentially between my family life and
my career i would have chosen my family
life and but i was busy in working and
while you have to be busy and working to
actually support a family so
but it's it's a it's a strange claim in
some sense right if you have a career
that's really moving forward at a rapid
rate how you can claim simultaneously
that your family is still the most
important thing to you it means partly
because part of the reason you have a
career if you have any sense is so that
you can bring
stability and opportunity to your family
and that means in some sense you can't
be with them all the time but they don't
need that anyways because they should
have some autonomy
so okay so but now you said too your
marriage
you said you drifted apart a bit with
your wife and so when this happened this
eight hour period that you're describing
did you think afterwards oh my god i
should have seen this coming or i did
see this coming or has it remained uh
has it remained a
shock to you and then what do you think
about the fact that it was a shock i
mean because obviously the thing to
wonder is well were were you willfully
blind and should have you seen this
coming and i'm not claiming that you
were i'm
these are you know they're genuine
questions but people are going to wonder
obviously
yeah well look i in the in the span of
eight hours i was ushered from my home
in handcuffs at the behest i later
discovered of my ex-wife um i was
committed to a mental institution
against my will the first of five
incarcerations uh there was also an
incarceration in and i called it
solitary confinement but it was a
singular jail cell
uh subjected to a temporary restraining
order in divorce court on the basis of a
false allegation that eventually was
disproven some six months later but by
then of course the reputation savaging
had been done and um it was all over by
the shouting i became homeless and
almost destitute overnight
uh and and lost
my you know my professional reputation i
wouldn't say it was irretrievably
destroyed but you know in the small
close-knit community that i lived in in
hollywood close to uh close to the
studios um it certainly took a big dent
and
everybody lives in a small close-knit
community like that if they're working i
mean the immediate people that you are
in contact with and working with
intensely tends to be a quite a small
number and it's quite interesting when
you get tarred and feathered
the
the people around you get afraid of the
contamination real real quickly and
that's partly because they look at what
happened to you and then they also think
well you know we don't really know what
went on in the marriage and people are
capable of terrible things and maybe
there were things that we don't know
about and then they're split because
they knew you and your wife and
and so it gets complicated instantly and
then it's easier for people just not to
have that much to do with you because
they also have choices right because
they know a reasonable number of people
and
it's then maybe you fall from number one
or number two on their list of people to
invite to like number fifteen and they
only ever invite the top ten
and so people don't even have to turn
their backs on you that much in order
for you to be
well friendless and so
these these and the allegation what
exactly was the allegation and why do
you think that your wife felt compelled
to to make it and how do you think she
rationalized that to herself if it
wasn't true
um
that's a great question uh she had been
diagnosed with panic disorder she wasn't
taking her medication she was out of
town
and she had called the police on this
particular day march 5th 2015 and she'd
asked them to come to the house i was
i'd actually taken the afternoon off i
was at home with my sons playing in the
play room with them and she asked them
to come to the house
and said that i was confused and the
dispatch said we can't go to the house
if he's confused she said well what do
you need to hear and they said we need
to hear he's a threat to himself or the
children and then allegedly sometime
later i think 45 seconds later
she uh she called them back and said uh
she said my husband's just told me quote
i'm sick of this [ __ ] i'm gonna harm the
children
end quote
and those ten words that ten word lie
was was the basis of
law enforcement coming first it was two
to my front door then it was three then
it was five and a sergeant and the
massing garrison uh the threshold of my
home
um without cause without a warrant
my rights were trampled
the police entered a smart team from the
dcfs department of children and family
services came in i was shackled in
handcuffs with a bar
uh behind my
behind my back in a quite affluent
neighborhood uh with the curtains wide
open on the thursday evening right well
that would be a little hard on your
reputation all right won't it
yeah i would say so
and then
they're going to think what are they
going to think they're going to think
the whole police system is corrupt and
that this is all made out of nothing and
he's actually innocent it's like it's
pretty damn hard for people to jump to
that conclusion
uh correct instantly yeah that's and
then and then of course what what then
with that what then happened was you
know i was kind of bundled into the back
of a
uh an unmarked police car and you know
raced off into the military one of the
actually one of the most heartbreaking
images i remember
was looking up from the back of that
police car um and seeing my son my
eldest boy charlie
and
joy that's rough man
seeing seeing my son
my son's childhood at 10 was over i knew
what was coming spousification
adultification
um the the vilification and the erasure
of me as a man as a father as a
patriarch as a provider
um and i was also heading into a
terrifying unknown a dystopian odyssey
i talk about it as if it's some kind of
kafka trap but it certainly was
kafka-esque and then of course the the
the word on the street i mean some of
the stories i later heard back were
absolutely insane i mean he's armed he's
psychotic he's i mean she was telling
everyone that i was psychotic and i was
bipolar all of these messages messages
came through my children as well when i
eventually got to see them and there was
no end in sight it was just down the
rabbit hole we go and of course i
thought i would get justice
uh
no no the justice system is mostly there
to stop people who can't reconcile their
differences from wreaking social havoc
that's basically what it's there for to
think if you do you think you're going
to go to the justice system and get
justice it's like
you'll be lucky if it doesn't destroy
you once you're tangled up in it
so near it nearly did it nearly
destroyed i mean it didn't it's amazing
that it didn't and that you managed to
to get through this and so okay so this
happened and then you're off to the
police station and the thing is the
police are going to view themselves in a
situation like that as white knights
right because they've come in
and you can understand that they've
committed to behest of a woman and god
only knows how abused she's been because
women do get abused and that's for sure
and so
and of course
the guilty act innocent just like the
innocent acting isn't probably the
guilty or even better at it and so
and then you're going to be viewed with
suspicion because men are going to be
viewed with suspicion in a situation
like this for sure where there's
allegations of abuse and that's because
there are a handful of bad men and then
bad impulses in all of us that you know
that can be dragged out one way or
another and
so
okay so
why did your wife double down on it do
you think
i think there's a i think there are
probably a few
possible reasons
one i think is shame uh the the emotion
or you know
we talk psychology is an extremely
powerful emotion
and i think once she'd let pandora out
of the box if you will i think the only
thing left was hope um and it was hope
for her existence i think there was
fear and panic that instilled in herself
about that suddenly after 20 years of
living a great life together and
building a great life and a great home
and a great family which is you know is
so important is my primary reason for
being um
[Music]
that she
perhaps was unaware somewhat of
the system and how the system comes in
and
forces i mean
you know
when i found out that the states get
reimbursed six thousand dollars for
every child um that they place into
foster care and four thousand children a
day lose a parent in family law
there are financial incentives in place
um and the adoption and safe families
act of 1974 offers financial incentives
to the states that increase these foster
or adoption numbers and to receive these
incentives and bonuses local
child protection services must have more
children they must have more quote
merchandise to sell
funding is available when a child is
placed in a foster home with strangers
or placed in a mental health facility or
medicated as it's called usually against
the parents wishes
so
um i think she was also her family
sister system of origin her mother
appalachian woman um
very proud woman twice married twice
divorced she would she came in strong
moved into the family home straight away
the same night she actually got back she
got to the family home before my ex-wife
returned when i was incarcerated and it
was that um psychological uh kind of
hammering home that you need to do this
you need to do that and when the cps
came in and said
you know you need to uh
you need to start divorce proceedings uh
you need to uh file for divorce you need
to file for restraining order otherwise
your children will go into foster care
that threat i'm sure must have been
terrifying for her as well so having
opened why did they threaten her
specifically that was the child
protection services why did they
threaten her with having the children go
into foster care was it because she was
hypothetically unable to protect them
from you
if she didn't take certain actions what
what was the reason it's my
understanding that this is what they do
this is the modus operandi of the cps
because they need to like traffic
wardens need to have enough tickets the
same people
if you ever get contact god help you if
you ever got get tangled up with child
protective services
that's that's right and i got i got a
few months later i managed to get the
report that the cps this woman oh this
this social worker from cps who came in
and ruined you know played a large part
in ruining my family with the system and
removing yeah well social worker
training is corrupt beyond belief it's
politically correct right to the bloody
roots and
and so the i you know the the many
social workers will come into a
situation without like that armed to the
teeth with the presumption that the
whole system is a patriarchal oppressive
system it's based on the exploitation of
women and children and they just need
the tiniest bit of evidence to make sure
that you're one of those patriarchal
oppressors who they're going to take
care of
and so that's drummed into them like mad
right from day one in social work
training and
and increasingly social work as a
profession is completely permeated by
ideologues of exactly that type it's god
help you if you fall into their hands
yeah i i couldn't agree with you more
i've learned this through my experience
and look my sons were they led a
privileged life it was an earned
privileged life you know i had to work
hard to get out of my small little town
in england and you know go to london and
you know i i want to get into the whole
earned and unearned privilege but that's
why i'm a believer in just the same as
offense isn't given it's only taken if
you choose to take it go ahead um
look we all have our privileges and our
disadvantages
and you know and some of them are earned
and some of them aren't earned and
hopefully we pay for the ones that
aren't earned by trying to be good
people and by taking the responsibility
of that unearned privilege forward but
it's only a fool and an ideologue who
goes after someone for their unearned
privilege because the same question can
be asked very quickly and very
effectively precisely of them now i went
to this hollywood
i don't know what to call it meeting on
someone's lawn once where everyone there
was talking about the one percent
and this was in like beverly hills and
it was in there it was on the lawn and a
mansion and i thought well i got up and
said
you people might not be in the one
percent by north american standards
because you're not you don't have a
hundred million dollars but you're in
the one percent by global and historical
standards it's like so who the hell
exactly are we talking about here with
this unearned privilege nonsense so a
little of that goes a long ways too you
know i mean
yeah i agree
yeah yeah yeah i was going to quickly
say you know my sons uh you know they
they
they led a a a privileged existence um
but they were connected to their mother
and their father their biological mother
and biological father we had a family
unit
um
and
just to see i mean you know a member of
the country club and i would take the
golfing every sunday and
family at least family dinner because we
were both out working but we would all
that was my thing we we come together as
a family um
if we can every day and definitely on
sunday for the traditional roast dinner
that we do in england
and then to read that report jordan
four months later after i'd been in the
fire a 53-page page report from the from
the dcfs and the social worker i wept i
wept as i read
you know the questions asked to my sons
has daddy ever touched your penis has he
ever put a needle in your arm i mean
the questions that my sons would just
and i was still well you think about
what questions like that do to kids it's
like
okay first of all
you're telling the kids that there are
adults that do this to children so
that's the first thing you're doing with
the questions and that's a bit of a
revelation to the average child who's
say eight or ten who's
really not being privy to such treatment
so you're confronting them with the idea
of malevolence itself
and you're a stranger and you're asking
them these weird questions that about
like deep malevolence and so what's up
with the institutions you might say and
then you're implying that their father
did this and if you're the typical
too typical social worker trained in
this sort of nonsense
there's the kind of insinuation that
goes along with that that's likely to
produce nightmares in the children and
phobias and there's a big documented
literature on that it's like the what do
they call that it's the false memory
syndrome essentially like if you get
into the hands of a bad therapist and
they start poking around in your memory
structure or or they can listen stories
from children there's great
documentation of all the daycare
remember the satanic abuse scandals in
the 1980s my god you read about what the
the social worker types and police too
what they did to children by asking
these leading questions
absolutely pathological and then you'd
get kids coming up with these fantasies
about what happened that were just
well
and then egged on by the police and the
social workers until there was a satanic
nightmare at the bottom of it and none
of it ever happened
one of the proudest moments i have uh
have of my sons at 8 and 10
getting to page 51 or 52 in that report
and they were asked about um
me as a father and how they rated me
having rated their mother and it was a
plus plus plus they they could so easily
to your point have been led
down the psychological garden path uh to
arrive at answers that were just
fantasies and not real um
but um that lasting impression that was
left on them one of the one of the
saddest i i
might
i i was i was forced to visit with my
sons
um
which the very notion of i remember one
father in family court who was told by a
judge you know visitation and he said i
will never visit my children they are my
children and he turned and walked out
and i'll never forget that i remember
looking back years down the line of
visitation where that led
because the visitation monitor happened
to be he had seven akas used to be a
woman had a criminal record um and he
drove around in you know
a car with with you know
stickers of guns and nra and not that
that's an issue but just it all added up
and there was nothing i could do and i
was getting blackmailed and there was no
one i could go to he was the only
conduit and then i found out that he was
there to supervise your visits
right to basically let you know
by by presence let my sons know that i
was dangerous to be around or to be a
feared which i never had been and every
piece of documentation in the visitation
reports at least for the first 18 months
was we love you dad we want to live with
you dad can't we see you and mom why
can't why is mum doing this
uh the first visit was uh dad mom says
to not get in the car with you because
you're gonna kidnap us and you have
biopolar i mean these these kinds of
things were just harrowing to me to hear
but there wasn't there wasn't really any
there's no there's nowhere to go there's
nothing to
there's no one to speak to but my
eight-year-old i remember one visit
i think was maybe my second visit my
eight-year-old not only had suicidal
ideations at eight years old my
beautiful innocent
playful lad
and he talked out loud about how he was
going to kill himself
and i had to listen to that as this
monitor listened to it and didn't even
consider it a critical incident to
report it and anyway
who's he going to report it to and what
are they going to do they would have
probably said that's just one
guilt
there you go yeah absolutely man
absolutely so
this is this is why jordan you know i i
came back like a phoenix from the flames
i was
dead and buried i mean i literally got
to that edge of existential terror
have you visited uh yeah i've been there
for quite a while yeah
for about two years
so
um i feel for you
and uh well i'm interested you know we
could talk more about my story but i'm
interested on
how we teeter on that long edge how we
well i was fortunate right the waves you
know i was fortunate maybe in contrast
to your situation because
what happened to me
didn't happen in a manner that severed
my closest intimate relationships
they were still intact and so when i got
very ill and was also being attacked
constantly
my friends and my family were like rocks
and so thank god for that but so i
didn't lose that and you know i i don't
think i would have lived if i would have
lost that too
and so
yeah i remember talking makayla came on
my show the respondent and we talked
about you know that whole situation i
again i was moved to tears the podcast
you did with her
when you came back and just your
struggle and and what you've given to
society and humanity and the uh
outrageous attacks um from cowards um
who who are you know
the cowards think they have courage and
they're they're placed on the pedestals
of of social media and uh and um
they're they're not um
and and with
with with what happened to me and my
boys
that led me on a journey i i
i guess the the big pinnacle moment for
me and i didn't read
that much at school i only read scripts
as i went through my career you know
whether it be screenplays or doing
voice-overs it was it was
2016. um
i went right to the edge
and i and i and i came back from the
edge and i don't know where this came
from but i asked myself
the meaningful question who am i
and i opened up my iphone and i did a
deep dive dialectical with meaningful
question and meaningful answer of the
thesis antithesis synthesis
and um i got over 1 000 uh answers and
questions i still have them and
and that led me through to learn a
little about
philosophy phenomenology affect theory
and
just epistemology in general and how i
could ritualize my way back to back to
be on my feet again because
i was fetal um
my i think my parasympathetic nervous
system was just shaking and i was and i
the blinds were closed i couldn't see or
hear another human being because there
was probably going to be a child
laughing which would remind me of the
devastation of losing my sons the
meaning of my life
and so i had to i had to really get in
that deep conversation with self
um
me self and the third eye perception and
and really get the walking going again
and the talking going again and
trying to get more precise with the
words i was thinking and expressing and
rebuild and reform and restore
not
the same life you know i say
we have two lives and the second life
begins the moment we realize we have
only one
but that new chapter that new episode
and how to
self-author if you will um
you know life is remembered backwards
and lived forwards well how can i
redraft that floppy disk in my mind if
you will or outside why did you decide
to bother
do you think i mean was
you know because i look you you tell a
story in the respondent of
well
it's not just an encounter
what would i say it's an encounter with
arbitrary with the arbitrariest form of
authority and and then that reputation
savaging you're accused of doing
something terrible it's so terrible that
it's very difficult for people not to
view you with tremendous suspicion as
soon as you're accused of that and so
then everything you have is stripped
away from you
well not everything that's the issues
like what isn't stripped away from you
and why did you decide to continue i
mean you you lost your career you lost
your reputation you lost your family
and then you're being pilloried
constantly and that's also really hard
psychologically because there must have
been part of you during all this that
was thinking
well i must have done something wrong i
mean
how can this like what did i do wrong so
that this occurred you know all these
people are after me and they're making
these accusations of malevolence and you
know who's the crazy person here exactly
is it this weird situation where it's
everyone but not me it's like that
sounds crazy so
how do you withstand that and and
i mean it must partly i guess the
positive responses of your sons must
have been
heartening under those conditions the
fact that when you did see them
you could still see that they loved you
and that that bond was still there and
so that's definitely a touchstone
it was for a while for a long while
but under the unrelenting inescapability
of the trauma you know trauma resides in
the body and the body keeps the score
and going through this i could see the
trauma that was being enacted on them
they lost their grief their living grief
i talk about suicide by living grief i
you know some of the fathers many
fathers some mothers too who are who are
no longer with us because of that
suicide by living grief the the
inescapability that there isn't a
finality to the grief there isn't a
finality to the mourning process to be
able to memorialize and later rest that
last chapter of my book i think it's
chapter 17 a funeral for my sons was i
had to find some way
to make meaning
in that moment
to
to later rest the childhoods that had
been stolen from them
and that sense of fatherhood and being
that father to them
um
so that that was
and then of course i had to find a way
to make to sense make through this and
and and find a way to help and give back
i think
you know the there was part of me that
uh
throughout my career had always been
what can i get what role can i get and
we're always living to the next to the
next projected moment of you know if if
you're on tour i'm playing this venue
can i get to a bigger venue next year
can i play to more people make more
money and that's the continuing
cycle of projecting into the next moment
not living in the now moment and that's
what can i get and where i moved to was
what can i give
how can i give you know he who has a why
can bear any how well i got to the how
and and and for me it was working
through
uh some kind of
story within my own story which made it
more more
traumatic because even writing the book
i hadn't really authored a book before
so i was having to revisit the trauma of
the experience and then read the audio
book and talk about it so it's this
perpetual cycle but fueling being able
to help people
being able to at least when it happened
to me jordan
i looked i looked online um you know for
i was the black sheep looking online for
some kind of help and hope and the only
thing available were
1 800 numbers for attorneys and law
firms in family law to make money and
books written by women
for women on how to ruin your husband
and get the cash and prizes the silver
bullets
[Music]
the only book i found was alec baldwin's
book a promise to ourselves
and i could only get 15 pages into that
because
he emailed me and said this is the best
i can offer right now read my book his
is literally it starts in the star
chamber of family law whereas my story
as you know it kind of that's the second
it's in three parts part one is fear
part two is loathing part three is
redemption and it moves into the second
part into the system and the systematic
uh institutionalized um
uh bias of of how courts perceive how
individuals within the court system
judges child psychologists perceive men
and fathers
and the family unit
and this
you know the neo-feminist kind of
radical fourth wave feminism that does
that devalues the patriarchy i don't
want to go go too down that
um um discussion yeah but well it's
worth it it's worth well you know
if
if the idea that marriage itself is a
patriarchal and oppressive institution
isn't far removed from the idea that the
nuclear family especially a two-parent
nuclear family is not to be preferred
say over a one-parent nuclear family so
what the hell difference does it make if
you break one up and how do you know the
father isn't just an oppressive
what would you say exploiter
because that goes along with the entire
rest of your philosophy and then you
might say well that's just philosophy
who cares it's like yeah you wait till
it gets all your leg you'll find out who
cares real soon because it's gonna be
you and you think that's not philosophy
it's like
you're gonna find out real different
real soon and you're not gonna like a
bit of it
yeah too true and when and when i you
know when i
when i looked into the stats
when i looked when i found out that the
world leader in children growing up in
single parent households was america
when i found out that 43 of american
children live without their father 63
percent of youth suicides uh from dad
deprived homes i know you've had uh dr
warren farrell on your show talking
about yeah the noted representatives
noted men's right fascist yeah
and yeah he's a real fascist old warren
farrell
but it's like where have all the mentors
gone well it's no surprise we don't we
don't have many men or as many men
stepping in well we're okay sending them
off to war
um but you know in terms of like
stepping into the public conversation uh
because you know because patriarchy
because smashing because believe all
we should listen yes but believe all
women no time's up good riddance um glad
they're gone done uh we look at
organizations like you know once great
storied organizations like the aclu yeah
um you know gone done over um can't be
trusted um
from the southern poverty law center
they're lots of fun too
yeah aren't they they're just a little
bit out of laughs yeah they are they're
just a blast those people
i mean look we when we have an industry
going back to family law when we have a
nearly 60 billion dollar a year american
divorce machine that's what the cartel
makes 60 billion
it's not incentivized to um
to to reform itself um
the whole divorce
industry
can feast on the accumulated wealth of a
once stable family and so that's right
obviously it's going to
produce a tremendous amount of parasitic
activity now that leads us to a deeper
question here too is look
many of the people in my immediate
family have been divorced
and so you know i don't ask such
questions lightly but
we did have a notion in our society for
a very very long time that divorce was
wrong
and
and as i said many people in my family
have been divorced and they had
difficulty in their marriages and
sometimes they establish much more
satisfactory let's say second marriages
but
it isn't obvious to me at all that
liberalizing the divorce statutes
especially in relationship to no fault
divorce which was supposed to be
you know an easy pathway forward has
produced anything but an absolute
absolute carnage and it's
in its wake and so
i
obviously having lived through these
problems you're very much inclined and
motivated to find solutions and and
what do you think of in relationship to
solutions
i mean i think i didn't believe this
when i was younger but i think
50 50 custody should be the default in
every divorce case and that both parties
should have to argue against that rather
than the presumption being that the
children
especially when young are better off
with their mother and i don't say that
lightly because
i know that particularly for children
under nine months old that maternal care
is really primary but
the fact that the default position is
custody with the mother
g puts men in an unbelievably bad
situation and so then the children as
well
i i couldn't agree with you more on 50
50 default shared parenting there have
been two states who've passed it
kentucky and arkansas kentucky
interestingly enough
they passed 50 50 shared parenting in a
large part because i believe it's
illegal for um
for the legal industry to lobby
politicians there and that's the
challenge is that when you have a such
it's such a huge very wealthy um
lobbying group the state bar
associations who write their own family
law codes in the wild west of family law
they write the codes and they spend
money at the last couple of weeks before
you know a bill has dropped and they lie
and they skew the statistics and people
believe them and bills don't pass but
kentucky did pass arkansas passed i've
been really excited to say what was that
um that was a cut i believe kentucky was
2019.
arkansas was more recent but just i
literally just heard a week ago um that
uh senator i've not sent us a
representative rodney creature in ohio
this is a bipartisan bill normally these
bills when they're put through
they usually have about 10 to 15
co-sponsors we now on that bill i have i
think we have 68 co-sponsors for an
equal shared parenting bill in ohio so
this is fantastic news for ohioans for
families for parents and for children i
think if we can improve the system and
at least through 50 50 shared parenting
we can ease the burden on the mental
health system the physical health system
incarceration rates dropouts from school
drug rates child porn addiction child um
online porn addiction one of the
stunning
issues of our time i would say is that
the statistics that two parent families
are better for children are absolutely
overwhelming
and so it's quite the mystery that it's
ignored and i i think part of the reason
that that fact is ignored is because of
this
pervasive
anti-patriarchal philosophy let's call
it that that because that particular
fact sticks so badly in the craw of that
philosophy that it has to be ignored
and so yes but then you ask yourself
well who are we for here are we for the
kids or for the adults because if we
were for the kids we'd be pushing two
parent families and then that's rough
too because if you say two parent
families are
optimal let's say
you're
you're faced with the necessity in some
sense of having to discriminate against
one parent families because if two is
better then one is worse and you know
then you point to the
single mother struggling valiantly
against all odds to do a credible job
with her kids and it's not like people
like that don't exist and then you're
such a son of a [ __ ] for daring to
compare her horrible struggle to what's
optimal but
well
yeah no it's a really good point and i
think you know given the way the the
system of government is set up it's it's
very challenging this system has got so
big that we almost need to blow it up
and start again i think um there's no
shortage of people working on that at
the moment yeah
not so much to start it again but
definitely blow it all up
yeah in terms of improvements for family
law i think look you know i'd mention
the presumption of innocence jurors
prudence you know i talked with uh
professor
robbie mccormick on on my show and we
talked about jurisprudence and family
and family law and the burden of proof
that must be on the accuser and not the
accused you know we we're in family law
in the salem witch trials we're in the
spanish inquisition 50 50 shared
parenting obviously a divorce must start
with the default presumption that what
is in the best interests of the children
is for both parents to equally share in
the parenting we saw with brad pitt's
divorce from angie jolie and the silver
bullet that was used against him and
then he worked tirelessly through the
retired judge and he won a victory quote
and quote a 50 50 shared parenting that
should have been that the default
starting position i think false
allegations of dv is something different
so that means okay let me push back on
that a moment okay because this is what
stopped me for years in relationship to
i suppose it was some intrinsic sympathy
for the mother infant bond
and some realization that the maternal
role is particularly important in the
earliest years of childhood development
so what do you do with infants exactly
do you go
do you go for 50 50 custody there as
well and then hope that the men have
enough sense to
to what exactly it's pretty hard to find
a substitute for a breastfeeding mother
you know i mean
now lots of breastfeeding mothers go
back to work and so obviously that can
be negotiated and maybe the issue is
that it should be 50 50 regardless of
the age of the child
and but then and how to what do men do
then when they have you know
custody of a night of a six-month-old
infant that's a real tough question yeah
that's a really good question i hadn't
actually thought about that you know
brad and angie's situation they didn't
have infants but obviously case by case
but but the point being that it starts
from the 50-50 and then immediately
there can be an order if there is an
infant that mother has you know primary
custody ninety-nine percent of the time
or whatever that sounds okay so it's
intense you think it should be it should
be negotiated away from the 50-50
baseline exactly there's two things
you'd really like to see change one is
the notion of the presumption of
innocence has to be brought within the
rubric of the family courts and and
implemented stringently and
and efficiently and the second is we
start from the default proposition that
it's 50 50 split what about what
happened to your assets let's talk about
that so you had you had
well we know that your career was
terribly disrupted but you'd built up i
would presume a reasonable degree of of
wealth by that point and so
what happened on that front
so
initially what happened when i was
removed from the from my home on march
5th and incarcerated the first visit
from my ex-wife and uh her mother uh
they arrived with no compassion they
basically slapped pieces of paper down
and pens and said write down the
usernames and passwords for all of the
financial institutions and the bank
accounts and
um and i trust you were in custody
yes yeah oh that must have been a funny
so what in the world were you thinking
when that was happening i mean because i
would say
go ahead yeah i was incoherent uh you
know i was i was i was i was dealing
with the terror
of being incarcerated in law enforcement
and something i wasn't used to um
and and hoping that they were going to
help and that they needed to do things
and pay bills and whatnot and then i
find out afterwards
the accounts got siphoned checks were
being you know corporate checks were
being my signature was being uh
forged and um but family
all of this evidence didn't seem to
matter uh so basically my you know this
the acquired wealth
uh from the bank accounts and the
brokerage accounts which is disappearing
i find out later and then the claim is
made that the house the family the
family residence was not mine and was
hers and when we met um
it's i think it's fair to say that my
career was was in a better position and
i brought more financially to the to the
place
to the start of the marriage but the
notion that she nearly won on that as
well
uh just would have been
devas i don't know if i'd if i'd be here
speaking with you if if i'd lost on that
uh on that point why that one
particularly
because because the accumulated what
i've been buying and selling properties
since i was 17 and started out as an
actor in london so the wealth that i'd
accumulated was in the house um you know
it's an expensive house and so the sale
of that house didn't really need there
wasn't very much of a tiny mortgage left
on it
so that was really the i put everything
into that house because i'm old school i
believe you know you own you know i
don't want to i don't want to owe money
to people in america i do this whole
credit system of you know you have to
get credit you have to get credit where
i come from it's like no you just if you
want something you buy it you own it um
and that's what i see so you put your i
see so you put all the eggs in that
particular basket and so yeah and that
wasn't taken away from you completely
because
um
well the title was the title to the
house was in my name and her name and as
much as she presented in court that it
was her house and i wasn't untitled that
piece of evidence um
was
pretty crystal clear um she couldn't
steal that
and was that was that part of the basis
for your ability to rebuild your
your security let's say
yes
yes i mean i was homeless for a while i
was homeless
for a good few months
for the kindness of a few friends who
gave me sofas and floors to sleep on and
why did they do that why did why do you
think they trusted you given everything
that had collapsed around you and all
the calumny that had been heaped on your
name
and why those particular people do you
think well it's a great that's an
insightful question that just makes me i
i look to what are the
commonalities between those individuals
they were all men
uh there was one woman um
so not all men most of the men
and they'd all been through divorces
i see i see so okay so so they have they
knew the character they they knew they
knew there was one one gentleman i
mentioned him in the book adam fogelson
who was the chairman of universal
studios he was he was he knew who i was
he i i
my his young his eldest daughter and my
my son were in pre-kindergarten together
i taught his daughter how to sing and
play piano and songwrite and
so he knew that he knew that even though
i was public enemy number one on the
streets and i was being vilified he
didn't believe it he his integrity was
so strong
that when the second time when i when i
finally got released or discharged
he had actually employed a security team
um
top-notch security team to track the
police scanners because they knew i he
knew i was going to come up for air
and of course i did at the neighbor's
house and then that was when there was a
team of i think 10 police this was the
second time five days later where they
you just banged on the door and i opened
the door and they dragged me out and
handcuffed me again and i got dressed
down by the sergeant and this this
gentleman just kind of stepped out from
the shadows and
had a word with the sergeant and and
kind of i got i got unhandcuffed and i
walked into what i thought jordan i
thought it was homelessness
and
and he said come with me someone's been
looking out for you and he too he walked
me to adam fogel's adam and hilary
fogelson's house
and uh and so you did have some
relationships there that withstood the
test of time you can imagine what would
happen if you lost that too man
so i had this client
his wife just he was a good guy hyper
conscientious professional
and uh his wife just
she she nailed him with accusations of
abuse and she was very attractive and
charming and very manipulative and
malevolent and
white nights were right into her aid all
the time and
he wanted to uh get 50 50 custody of his
kids and she
she first of all with the allegations of
abuse destroyed his professional
reputation so that means he lost all his
clients in his profession and then she
accused him of hiding the money because
he was having a hard time making alimony
payments because he couldn't make any
money because his profession had been
ruined and so then he set himself up
again providing health care to basically
indigenous people on
social services and then he made a go of
that and then she accused him again in
court of having money that he was
drawing on so they froze his bank
accounts and
and uh
and and garnishing his wages and so that
made it very difficult for anybody to
hire him and then
they could take away he had to drive to
work because he could no longer work
close to where he lived and then they
took away his driver's license because
they can do that without court in canada
and so then he couldn't drive and then
they took away his passport because they
could do that too
and so in the meantime to take him
through court to
siphon the last penny out of him and
deny him access to his children and i
went out with him and his children
several times and they were all
let's see two
three and five i think three boys we
went out to the science museum which is
a challenging thing to do with three
young kids and he showed up on time on
the van and he walked those kids through
that science museum and they just had a
wonderful time and i watched him like a
hawk and he was a really good father
and
she pursuing him her father mortgaged
their house and
she spent all their money at which they
deserved very nicely because they had
raised her to be just exactly the way
she was and
it was just a bloody disaster
i worked with him for like three years
trying to help him
negotiate through this without dying you
know just because he wanted his kids and
i pulled out every stop to strategize
and we were careful and he did what we
negotiated and and he was really
dedicated to his kids and he just got
ground up man and then all this stuff
blew up around me and
around that time
story what you talk about right there i
think i think you i think i heard you
mentioned that maybe a few years ago
that particular story it may have been
that one when you were when you were in
practice but
um that speaks to there is no escape
it's the zero-sum game of of family law
and it is a game to these attorneys and
it's not just no escape for me uh as a
respondent it's no escape for the
petitioner to like johnny rape and his
situation right so
you know the false allegation of
domestic violence it's it's we need to
remind people johnny depp has not been
found not only
not been found guilty of any crime he's
not been accused of any crime um
he's been tried and found guilty in the
court of public opinion guilty till
proven more guilty and i think it's that
it's those kinds of um
you know
that in inability to escape the divorce
trap there's no trap door there's no way
out for both parties um and you know my
my ex-wife spent
i i believe it's 1.8 million dollars
on an
attorney her attorney judy bogan
um and then after four years this
attorney just filed to the court to be
released from the case and i believe is
now suing my ex-wife for 450 000 on top
of that
so the the blatant plundering of an
estate
um
and how someone you've you've worked
your whole life you've you've
you know started from
not a lot
and you've you've plowed your field in
your career
and the notion that just because you
have a marriage contract um
because you know i
i believe in monogamy i believe in
family obviously i made some missteps
along the way i mentioned those in the
book i was you know flawed one thing i
wasn't was a bad if i was a great dad i
will
shout that to the rooftops i was a
brilliant father my sons
loved me and i loved them so if it could
happen to me
and it can happen to johnny depp brad
pitt it can happen it's it it's it's
happening and it has happened for
decades from my research to so many
people and there's a voiceless
growing group of people who've had
enough well the guys the guys that it
really happened to
you don't even hear from them they're so
done man some of them are just dead and
the ones that aren't dead they're
they're done they're exhausted they're
friendless they're
struggling
i've talked about the child support
hustle you know skip child support go to
jail lose job repeat you know poor to
your point poor non-custodial parents
many times forsaken fathers or or the
patriarch or the dad who lack the
ability to pay child support end up in
modern day debtors prisons if you will a
person who fails to pay child support
can have their driver's license yeah
exactly professional license and
passport revoked um you're without any
money
yeah yeah and that's just that's just in
the hands of the bureaucrats who all
that's turned over to none of that has
to go through court it's like you didn't
pay okay we'll start stripping you of
that which makes it possible to you to
make a living so that's really going to
be helpful you're probably hiding money
and then maybe you're working below your
capacity just for revenge and that's not
acceptable either it's like yeah that's
i mean some people might be pushed to
that extreme
you know because they think well
how do you be motivated when your money
is being stolen out from underneath you
no matter what you do it's kind of going
to take away a certain amount of your
drive to provide let's say especially if
you don't have access to your kids
anymore as well turns you into a kind of
slave
well that's just it it's you know judges
can can set the payment on presumed
income presumed income yeah yeah
is actually making causing fathers to
enter and sometimes mothers but mainly
fathers a crushing cycle of
incarceration i remember talking with
one father who was in prison he was in
jail in new york and there was a bail
reform and they let everyone out apart
from the dads who owed child support
and of course while they're inside the
interest is accruing and if they manage
to pay the debts the fines and and high
interest rates charged uh
the
that money doesn't go to the custodial
parent it's going to the state so the
state that's its power the additional
problem here is you know there's going
to be young men listening to this and
they're going to be thinking oh my god i
better never get married and so this
whole catastrophe is undermining the
idea for young men that marriage is
something that anybody sensible would
ever enter into but then that doesn't
really help either because if you live
with someone for six months or a year
you're basically common law at least at
some point along the way and it doesn't
matter anyways you so what are you
supposed to do just forego
you know permanent relationships with
women all together because
well that's hardly a solution
although it's a solution that not so
many that that a non-trivial minority of
young men are seriously considering and
there are many reasons for that but this
is one of them
yes why would why would you i mean i was
talking with someone the other day
through my charity about an app they
have called i do
and it it basically
it marries you and divorces you
automatically so
within a time frame that will save you
from actually paying you know alimony
and and
and
and and it's worked out by the state
that you're in i mean the notion that
that we have to contract marriage that's
where i arrived i believe in marriage
but the institution
now the way it's set up it's just it's
it's a fool's errand
had i known now what i knew then why
can't we get married in the eyes of god
or the eyes of religion or the eyes it's
a spiritual place of worship whatever
you whatever the couple decides to to to
enact that that union ceremony um why
does it have to be
a contract with the state that the state
can then come in
and dis and negotiate without my say
without either say
they can not even only negotiate they
could
take away what they want when they want
so it's it's a real it's a real
challenge like where's the
where's the um
you know the ideological line in terms
of i believe in marriage but i would
caution
i would caution younger people well then
the question then is what exactly are
you doing when you caution it
because
you know yes but with caution well
exactly what do you mean by that and and
the answer to that is well it's by it's
by no means clear i suppose the answer
to that lack of clarity is something
like well the laws need to be changed
they seriously need to be changed and so
presumption of innocence would be a nice
start and default 50 50 custody what
about splitting of assets like where do
you stand on that i mean i can't help
but think that it's absurd in some sense
that paul mccartney's ex-wife got half
of his fortune it's like and perhaps
that's not exactly true but you know
what i mean
and the
we are talking about a default 50 50
child custody
arrangement is the right arrangement in
relationship to assets 50 50
once the marriage takes place and is
that also true and i'm out of my legal
depth here is that also true in the case
of common law marriage and should it be
the case
yeah common law i'm i'm not too up to
speed on that um
i would say you know again it's you know
i've been talking with another
technology company about a software they
have what in divorce called what's
called a disa master so all of the
financial numbers the forensic account
accountancy all of those numbers go into
this machine and it spurts out what
people have to pay what people receive
in terms of child support and alimony
and uh this app actually would take in
that that information before during and
after if there isn't after while people
are married and if they decide to
separate
to actually calculate who brought what
how they brought it but it's again
how do you determine that uh because the
value of god the value of the moment i
mean that's a quick route to divorce
right there man trying to negotiate all
that well absolutely because you partly
what you do in a marriage is you enter
into it and you have to with trust
because otherwise how can you enter into
it and the trust has to be
i presume that you're going to do the
right thing here and you presume that
for me and will struggle forward trying
to do that and
if we have to
if we have to negotiate the terms of our
eventual dis union
well it's like we're negotiating the
disunion right now and so
i just can't see how that's going to
work well and so
look what do you if you look back
what is
you must ask yourself this like a
hundred times
what did you do wrong do you think that
led to the dissolution of your marriage
or is that an unreasonable question
what did you bring to the table that
made things go sideways you said you
were a great father and so you're ready
for that but your marriage went sideways
and
and
why
well the part that i'm responsible for i
can talk to that uh i wasn't monogamous
i wasn't faithful um
that was probably the biggest she found
out after all this happened that that
was the case
um
so that would be i would say the the
kind of biggest
factor
do you think that this marriage
dissolution would have taken place if
that had not been the case i mean
because
i'm sorry to push you but i'm going to
because this is so bloody important you
know and what happened to you is so
terrible that every and happens to many
men and not insignificant number of
women it's so terrible that it needs to
be delved into deeply and so you were
looking for something outside the
marriage obviously and perhaps that was
because there was something that wasn't
in the marriage or god only knows why
um and so
that was an emotional intimacy that was
you go ahead yeah i was gonna say there
was an emotional intimacy there wasn't
physical intimacy the sex had dried up
uh after after the you know first kid
and we i tried talking about it you know
the male sex drive was there it is there
yeah so let's uh okay so let's go into
that that's a good one because that
happens to lots of people in their
marriage you know i mean yeah
and and it happens as you get older and
it happens as you have kids because you
know you have
15 priorities but only 10 of them ever
get
implemented and maybe like number 14 is
sex or something like that and so
it goes away and it's really hard for
people to negotiate and you said
you
you tried to talk about it
i guess i would like to know
how hard did you try and how many times
and how insistently and why didn't it
work
i mean because if i have clients in this
situation and i'm talking to both of
them i wasn't a marital counselor but
sometimes i would talk to both it's like
how often do you think you should have
sex let's get a range here okay
zero times per year is too few
and like twice a day that's too many so
now we got we got the
parameters defined here right so we're
not going for zero we're not going for
you never get out of bed we're going for
something in between that and so
we might look at
what's acceptable for the average couple
and maybe that's something like
twice a week or three times a week and
that's a place to start
and so
because it's not optional this isn't
optional exactly
and you say well you're gonna you're
gonna turn it into a routine you're
gonna take all the spontaneity out of it
it's like well how's that spontaneity
going for you exactly
it's like well we haven't had sex in six
months
so
yeah it's really important and really
great points and i think as well it's
not just the sex i mean there is yeah
you know there is there is emotional
intimacy there's affection there is um
you know um
yeah well hopefully that's all part of
the that's all part of sex when it's
really working properly like i had this
one client who is terrified of women to
a degree you can't possibly imagine and
he was so terrified of women he couldn't
even get near one and he was in his 40s
and he had his problems believe me and
that was one of them and his mother who
was about 80 was still taking care of
him to some degree and she needed to
because he had a lot of impairments that
were real and and profound
and i suggested to her that i take him
to a strip club because that was the
only place i could think of to expose
him to women in any possible sense and
she was a very conservative person this
woman but she agreed immediately and so
we went once a week for quite a long
time
one of the things i really learned when
i was there that a lot of the men that
were there were there for
emotional intimacy for whatever they
could get for some touch like you think
it's pure sexual gratification but and
of course that element is there but
most of these men were desperately
alienated and lonesome and they were
there at and i'm not being naive about
this i've been in strip clubs i know
what they're like
but that
the idea that
what you're negotiating in a
relationship when you're negotiating sex
is just the the climax let's say that's
just wrong you're negotiating
physical intimacy
and that's not optional you know like
babies die without physical intimacy and
children don't grow up properly unless
they're played with and touched and
cuddled and
even animals are like that and and so
this negotiation is of crucial
importance and so i'll go again you said
that you you talked about what happened
when you talked about it
it was shut down i mean how i was
insistent at times i was i would
continue to revisit the subject i would
implore to go and speak with a
professional um therapist right well
there's nothing sexier than a man
imploring
well sure
darling let's go
yeah
no but that was one of the tactics i
mean that was you know you have to you
have to deploy multiple tactics i tried
courtship i tried you know i was
exasperated at times you know look if
what do you what do you think i i would
you expect me to do go outside the
marriage
you know yeah i i i have to there has to
be some you know patients
what do you think what do you okay so
when i was doing this professionally
we'd start with these you know framing
frequencies let's say and then we would
these were people who entered into this
in good faith so they were trying both
to move forward we'd say well you know
what have a date this week and
what you do as a marital counselor or
sexual counselor in situations like that
when people haven't been intimate for a
long time you say what you're going to
go going to have two dates this week or
maybe one
and you're going to hate it because it's
awkward and you don't like each other
and you're you know you're
you're separated from each other but
here's the first rule is no sex to
consummation
zero that you do not do that to begin
with and so you kind of have the person
revert to the first stages of what would
have been a protracted courtship right
and you go out and you have dinner and
then they come back the next week and
they say i say how to go and they say it
was awful we just all we did was fight
we're never doing that again
and the answer was well i see you're
never doing that again they
it's like
that's your solution
no romance now for the rest of your life
you're just going to live and you're
going to hate each other that's your
solution how about you need to do this
20 times before you're not absolutely
bloody awful at it
and so with
but it's very hard you know if you
haven't been trained to think about such
things like that you don't know that you
need to take 10 steps backwards you
don't know that you need to forbid full
sexual contact for a while while you're
kind of reintroducing it and and and
this of course as i said this was being
negotiated
between two people and me let's say
they had already agreed that they were
going to do what they could to fix this
so they were both kind of even though
they're resistant to it in their
individual ways they were both willing
to experiment to find a solution and i
don't know what you do if you have a
partner that just
refuses point blank to go there well i
think you you said it right the
willingness to experiment and and and
have a little nuance and a little doubt
to rekindle and revisit maybe why
you came together to kind of that
nostalgic savoring of the first meeting
or the first few times and
to
try something new yeah well that one of
the things i often did with people was
ask them okay well what attracted you to
the other person to begin with you know
and then they'd usually get misty-eyed
both of them when they were talking
about that because they weren't that
happy that their love had disappeared
so okay so then i'll ask you a
deeper question than that so
why do you think your wife was unwilling
to engage in those negotiations with you
i mean it could be we could say well
lack of skill on your part in the
negotiation and that's who the hell
knows how to negotiate such things it's
not easy
you know and it's not like we have
professional training in negotiation
even though we should because people are
so bad at it's just beyond belief they
have no idea where to start
and so
so why do you think you hit a brick wall
what did it did you wait too long to
start or
i think i think i floundered because of
much of what you talked about in terms
of negotiation you know too many
from what i know now
um i didn't know then in terms of the
use statements rather than the i
statements leading with the eye rather
than the right
communication the the the the way to um
you know the
the way to understand and collaborate
through and negotiate through without it
being serious to to to do it together to
put demands or non-negotiables down not
that i did it was just an exasperation
yeah yeah well couples will come in
they'll say
to one of them will say to the other
like you never want to have sex with me
and it's been like that for two years
and i don't see that it's going to
change in the future it's like well the
other person is set on their heels right
away because
you basically said
you've been bad for a long time you're
bad now and i can't see how you're going
to change it's like oh my god how are
you going to start from that and then
maybe in a situation like that you ask
the person
well if you could have the sex life you
wanted
what would it look like
and you can ask each of them that and
then well then you know at least you got
a mutual vision there and they're right
i would say men generally
would like to have sex more frequently
than women i don't think i'll probably
get pilloried for that comment but i
don't think anybody reasonable would
deny i agree with you and i'll get less
pilloried but probably pilloried too
yeah well it's generally the case not
always the case but
you you can meet in the middle that's
for sure or no that i shouldn't say that
because that's not exactly right what
you want to do is you want to elaborate
out a vision then you want your partner
to elaborate out a vision and then you
want to create a joint vision that's
better than both of those that's
sustainable and then it's not
compromised exactly but if you start
with accusations which you're likely to
do if you're frustrated and you have
been for like three years
and things are already sideways you're
just not going to go anywhere and the
other person will dig their heels in and
and then they you know they hit you with
counter accusations and you know it's
one of the things terrible failing of
our education system is that yes the
rudiments of negotiation aren't taught
it's real i agree but particularly
interpersonal relating i mean this is
one thing we haven't you know the
charity that i started cpu children and
parents united we have three basic you
know focuses in terms of what we are
programs and what we want to do and what
we are doing
um and the first one is communication
you know we've been talking with warren
farrell about bringing his couple's
communication in and
not just couples but you know
interpersonally relating throughout the
generations and friends and because to
your point when trust breaks down
how do you how do you get that back you
know we need to dr john gottman talks
about um
you know one negative comment has
way more power than 50 positive comments
so how do you undo that negative yeah
you can tell that if you go on twitter
and see how you respond emotionally
yeah well it's also easier to pick up on
this so you know the other thing i used
to talk about one other thing i used to
talk about with my clients was
well here's a here's a tactic
how about you watch your partner real
carefully and whenever they do something
you would like them to do more of you
tell them that you saw it and and you
and tell them that you're happy about it
that's really hard because
generally
we let normal go unnoticed and we even
let good go
un
rewarded or you could really be foolish
and punish someone when they do
something good like maybe you're a bit
jealous and your wife goes out of her
way to make herself look attractive when
you're going out for a date it might be
an indication that she has some sense
that maybe at some point in the future
she might sleep with you but because
you're jealous you don't compliment her
wardrobe or you say something snarky
about it and then it's like do that
three or four times and she'll never
dress up for you again
ever
and then it's done you know and so
this idea of watching people and then
seeing
when they do something you'd like them
to do more of and then telling them
that's really i think i think that's
good i think that's a really powerful
thing and you know that's something that
um to your point can be it's hard to
take on new
uh
new routines new
ways of being effective of expressing
affection uh if you're not used to it if
you're more stoic or if you're but it it
we have to i think we have to give what
we'd like to receive and i think we all
like to receive platitudes and uh
affirmations and uh
you know that was lovely that you did
that sweetheart yeah especially if it's
specific especially if it's specific you
know you say hey look i just saw what
you did
here's what you did that was specific
and like yes thank you that's great yeah
that's great
you know and it's funny too because you
do have to negotiate details you know
it's
well think well how often do you want to
be hugged it's like i don't want to talk
about it it's like yeah no kidding you
don't want to talk about it but like how
about never
okay never seems a bit dismal so okay
let's see if we can do a little better
than never so maybe you have a couple in
and you're talking to them and you think
well
why don't you try once a day
or do i just try once this week and come
back and say how it went then you have
to be patient with your partner because
if you've been estranged from them
physically
and you're doing this hug because your
idiot therapist told you it was a good
idea
it's going to be perfunctory and a bit
cynical
but it's a hell of a lot better than
nothing and so you come back and you're
kind of irritated about you say well
okay you're practicing and you're not
very good at it so it didn't go that
well but
try it this week twice and see if you
can just do it a little better
and that works you know but you got to
be
humble enough to know how stupid you are
when you start and it's pretty pathetic
how bad you are well you can also laugh
you can also find find ways to laugh
about it i think yeah in the room if
you're with a third if that third is a
therapist you don't leave with the third
you know so as much as a therapist can
have ideas it's i think it does have to
come down to
the individuals who actually
take that suggestion and really believe
in it and want to actually move it
forward in a positive way oh yeah yeah
yeah
because therapists actually can't give
advice you know
you can only ask people it's like you
can say well how often do you want to
get hugged
they don't say never it's like okay it
isn't never so you know is it once a
week or something but you have to ask
and if you just if you just ask if you
just tell people to do things they just
won't do them they can't even tell
themselves to do things and do them it
has to be negotiated
you can't you try not you tell yourself
to do things christ no you won't listen
well
the conversation was oh i always say you
know the two most important parts of the
day uh waking up and going to bed and
those mini rituals and if you go to bed
to sleep then you're not going to fall
asleep you go to bed to rest sleep will
handle itself great um how many times
i'm just curious how many how many times
do you like to be hugged are you a
hugger
yes i mean you must have a lot of people
who come up to you and want to hug they
have like a lot
right yeah yeah that's fine it's fine
man i don't mind that at all i mean with
my i'll give you an example of how this
works when my daughter
my daughter's a year and a half older
than my son and so kids that are spaced
less than three years apart have a
pretty
high risk of fairly severe sibling
rivalry and that can get really out of
hand and it's partly because the older
child is still pretty young to have an
interloper in you know and as all also
is called upon to be quite mature very
rapidly because when you have a one and
a half year old and no other children
you think that's a pretty young kid but
then when you have a newborn you think
oh no that's an adult man it's just a
short adult and so there's a big demand
on the child to
mature and so then she she or he can get
jealous of the infant and that can
really
wreak havoc
so
we
trained our daughter repeatedly to come
and get a hug and we practiced it it was
like
come and get a hug and we practiced that
till she got really good at it and we
said whenever you're feeling upset you
just come over and get a hug and then
you can have some attention and so
sometimes my wife and i would have a hug
and we'd have the kid come in between us
and then
she could have a hug too
and so by the time this our son was born
she was an expert at coming to get a hug
and so whenever she got upset she could
just come get a hug and
but that took like you have to train
someone to do that and you think well
you don't have to train that it's like
you would be surprised what you have to
train and what you have to learn in
practice and you know what yeah and also
it reminds what it reminds me of jordan
is my youngest my eldest boy when he was
born he went to kindergarten
pre-kindergarten in kindergarten
we would tell him because we as new
parents we were listening to the school
and it was a very
you know hollywood school it was like a
hollywood school house it was all use
your words use your words so we drilled
this into him use your words use your
words then he he went to kindergarten
and he you know he got the crap kicked
out of him every day he was bullied
mercilessly from kindergarten through
first grade no support from the school
and realizing that the tool of use your
words doesn't make it doesn't do any
good when a big kid is coming up and
punching in the face so you know then my
youngest son um it was slightly
different and he's a little and this may
be a you know second sibling uh thing uh
second born of his boys i don't know but
that right of passage of you know just
being a little bit more rough and tumble
and rough housing the importance of that
um you know going back to the the issue
of father's day you got to use your
words man but you got to have something
to back them up with oh yes
absolutely and kids are really good at
sussing that out real quickly especially
the bully types like they'll come along
and poke you it's like anything to you
no oh well then i can just pretty much
steal everything you have including your
reputation and your happiness and there
isn't a damn thing you're going to be
able to do about that you think well
kids aren't like that it's like no
you're just naive and like heaven help
your kids because being naive as a
parent's not that helpful for your kids
and there's plenty of bullies on the
playground and plenty in adulthood too
so aren't there there are
you've experienced quite a few
um but you seem to be holding your own
and you seem to be you seem to be back
and um
you know
getting into a full schedule again i see
you going on tour
yeah yeah well thank god for small
mercies you know and for all the help i
had too so but yeah hey so
tell me what happened with your kids how
old are they now your boys
17 and 15 my youngest turned 15 on
november 22nd the day before
thanksgiving um
they
they
i don't see them i don't hear from them
um
my arms are outstretched wide open for
if and when
and maybe one day they will
there will be that reckoning um
you know so why do you think that why
why is it that they're not seeing you
what
what happened as far as you can tell
parental alienation parental alienation
is child abuse plain and simple it's
brainwashing and it's clear if you look
at the history of our family and then
for the 18 months the first 18 months
that i was mired in court and had to
have a visitation monitor that they you
know i actually published this in my
book at the end the two uh independent
psychological evaluations that i was
forced to partake in and pay for i
published those one is 2015 and one is
2019 in december at the end neither
judge looked at either of them or cared
but in the first one in 2015 december
2015
the psychologist the psychiatrist
included 70 i think was 69 monitored
visitation reports and it's clear and
unequivocal that my sons are suffering
they love me they say in every report i
love you dad we love you dad i love you
dad we want to live with you and the
system didn't care um
and so
that
that spoke highly to me that this system
needs reform it needs improving on a
personal basis
they
now have this image of me having not
been around that i'm someone to be a
feared
that i can't be trusted that i'm
dangerous um and none of that is the
case and none of that is true but um
jesus
their psychologies
that their psyches have been so cemented
uh at such a young age 10 and now you
you talked about grief too you know and
the never-ending
consequence of of this grief that comes
from separation without finality it's
like they must have been experiencing
that too and yeah at some point
you know
they can't in the house of betraying the
matriarch if they any time i remember
the youngest where it was a year in
jordan and and oh my god we had a visit
and he called me on the phone i still
kept the voicemail it kept me going it
gave me
it was medicinal fuel for me to just
hear his voice and know
what it sounded i knew always know what
it sounded like but he called me and he
was like dad dad and then his older
brother was like get a phone don't hang
up the phone we're going to be in shoes
trouble with mom and he hung up the
phone and it's that's right fear the
irrational paranoid
fear of of
me yeah well at some point it's got to
be easier for them to let you go than to
be torn apart on a day-to-day basis
when i realized yeah when i realized
that that they were after
four years of monitored visitation i
finally got
a visitation without a monitor
uh watching my every move and writing it
down and then i realized that they were
they were both and they weren't allowed
to have their iphones with them their
phones with them on visits mom wouldn't
let them
but they both had their phones and they
were sticking they were videotaping and
then and then i i
it became clear to me through other
channels that they may have been fitted
at least one of them with um body
cameras and when it got to that place i
when my sons are being used as a tool
against me
to try and record incriminating evidence
that there has to be an end to that for
them so part of why i i came to some
kind of resolution and ending on it
um and i gave up so much i mean she
wouldn't even give me through the
settlement agreement she wouldn't give
me the rights to know to let me know if
i either of our sons were on life
support and the button was gonna the
switch was gonna be you know permission
was gonna be given that they would die
she wouldn't she wouldn't legally have
to let me know and but i didn't even
realize at the time that every
everything in our settlement agreement
that
that i got which was very little
she hasn't held to anyway because she
knows that ultimately it's going to cost
tens of thousands of dollars to go back
to court in the same system zero some
and so on
one of the things i learned
from being a clinician was that
restraining orders only work on the
people on whom restraining orders work
for example so i had some clients who
had like six restraining orders on them
one of them i remember he was really
paranoid he was he was hard to deal with
i got somewhere with him but it's very
hard to deal with a paranoid client and
he was clinically paranoid and it's like
nda's non-disclosure agreements that you
know really they aren't worth the paper
they're written on because people are
just going to do what they're going to
do
yeah yeah yeah so enforcing that's very
difficult he used to say to people if
they annoyed him
now and then he'd get tangled up with
someone who was bureaucratic in their
inclinations and he'd say i'm going to
be your worst nightmare
and you know sometimes you might want to
say that to someone but you don't really
mean it
he really meant it so it takes
restraining order oh yeah you have no
how do you how do you i'm curious okay
because this is the false allegations of
dvs and tros i mean
you know
over seven i think it's around over 70
percent and i'd have to check on the
stat of domestic abuse allegations
resulting in a tro a temporary response
tr yes temporary temporary restraining
order or epo emergency protection order
are not sustained
once the case moves to a permanency or
evidentiary hearing but this shows that
the majority perhaps the majority of
domestic violence allegations are
perhaps false or unprovable
um and i think yeah this correlation
what's going on
the rub there
go ahead yeah yeah the the correlation
with cancel culture and victimhood being
the new social currency um this is an
affront to the real victims of domestic
violence so how do you tackle
uh
this the false allegation the perjurer
if the allegation works every time
the question is absolutely well then the
question is too how do you stop people
from using systems there that are there
to protect the vulnerable from being
used as weapons
you think well people wouldn't do that
it's like yeah yeah you just wait till
you tangle with someone who'll do that
and you'll change your yeah who is right
i don't know why people always make that
particular noise when they hear about
such things but
yeah yeah
i've seen those systems well they've
been weaponized against me continually
but i've seen people just brought to
their well same-sex same place you were
brought to it's like yeah get tangled up
with child protection services for a
week and see what your life is like
an hour
yeah false allegations that these false
allegations that are used in family law
to thwart the non-resident parent and
child relationship
need to be dealt with in a way that
protects the relationship that is under
attack and in a way to dissuade the
making of these allegations or
accusations going forward and one of the
things we could one of the things we
could warn people about in this podcast
is if you're thinking about making such
allegations
don't be so sure that your own arm won't
get tangled up in the machine
because it's you think you know you're
gonna leverage this this enterprise to
punish your partner and you're maybe
you're willing to do that because you've
been pushed to your limit in some sense
or maybe just because you're feeling a
bit malevolent it's like
you wear loose clothing close to that
machinery and you're going to get pulled
in and spit out and so it won't just be
you going down the negative pathway and
the problem with that is is that some
people they get so
inclined to wreak havoc and to extract
revenge that they're perfectly willing
to hang themselves in the window to
block out their neighbor's sunlight
let's say
yeah if you're gonna if you're gonna go
on a journey of revenge dig two graves
you know yeah that's right that's for
sure you know
and when i this is what i think about
with you know the pandora's box that she
let
she let out the only thing that was left
was hope is is those who you know god
will forgive our sins our nervous system
won't um and that yeah i this is this is
that false allegation you know that
technique and tool being weaponized
for financial gain i just wonder when
this will reach uh yeah we have a
president in america we have president
who's a catholic father and grandfather
and the violence against women act was
his act in 1974.
and that that's a series of it was a
series of law enforcement grants that
shifted the focus away from the problems
of
um the relationship to a law enforcement
approach to domestic violence resulting
in a shift from the prior discretionary
approach to mandatory arrest or
detainment policies
and and i think that
that's the kind of
holding space now like purgatory where
like in my case jordan when the police
came
they couldn't arrest me i've never been
arrested they couldn't arrest me because
i hadn't committed a crime
but they had to remove me because i was
seen as a danger
where do they take me they can't put me
in a prison cell for long because i i
would need my miranda rights read to me
i'd need an attorney and access to one
you know where people like me end up
5150 holds you know those who need to be
on 50 150 holds where they end up
because they were thrown out prisons
so you know those who are actually
emotionally disturbed who need help and
need assistance go to the worst place
possible for them jail and prison
prisons our prison system and those men
and sometimes women like me
who have a false allegation false
accusation made
there is no real place for the system to
so the police used to have discretion
and now
all this money that president biden
created through pushing through his his
act and by the way vawa the violence
against women act as being you know it's
being looked at again uh they call it
stop grants it was money for stop grants
so to qualify for these stop grants law
enforcement had to adopt these policies
of mandatory arrests
so
you know forcing
law enforcement to prosecute
or persecute every man who's accused of
domestic violence to keep the coffers
full like this is the incentivized
structure that we have so how can we
change that
that then you know yeah well i guess we
start to change it by having
conversations like this right and trying
to specify what the problem is because
it's really complicated what the problem
is and then what the solution should be
on a legal basis what the solution
should be ethically and on an individual
basis
so you know a thousand conversations
like this is a place to start so i think
so too and i think i think more uh
proactive solutions i mean that's what
i'm trying to do through
through my new fledgling charity is to
have
um you know the communication programs
where can people find out about that
that's children and parents united where
yeah that's right now
sorry go ahead with the charity
yeah right now children parents united
or cpu is our mission is to promote and
improve child well-being
uh by providing information and
resources to
policy makers um
the public um practitioners resulting in
in reduced conflict and enhanced
uh relationships uh for those children
and parents negotiating our current
family law systems and we have three the
place to find that is the respondent.com
we will we'll be launching the
the website for the charity soon but
right now it lives at the respondent.com
but
we have three cost-effective practical
solution-based programs right now
communication workshops and programs
that we're working out and developing
that promote improved interpersonal
relating
mediation
cpu mediation which we call it is to
provide mediation services i just
actually i mediated my first case i
wanted to do one myself just to see um
and it was a couple who'd been in family
law for six years spent nearly two
million dollars no resolution i was able
to find resolution and settlement within
six hours on a saturday and three hours
on a certain way because that's a way
different process than trying to get
each person all they can grab from the
spoils of the relationship
yeah it's like it's like it's not i was
i heard someone tell me once it's not
you don't get what you deserved it's
what you can live with
because you're always going to walk away
from mediation you know feeling somewhat
aggrieved yeah at least you could walk
away
right uh yeah you have
life
um and then the other is a public
interest law firm providing legal advice
so that supports the mediation process
oversees the legal legal procedures uh
so that if people do want to get
divorced that they do want to separate
long term
um that that there's the ability to
actually draw up those legal agreements
and uh
and deliver them but really we just need
to keep people out of court i joke that
we are the red cross of divorce we're
growing and building out but we need
resources and infrastructure and we're
hoping to get that um because hopefully
this podcast will help so that's
children and parents united and that's
at it's at the res
what's the dot com
respondent dot com
and that's after your book the
respondent exposing the cartel of family
law which is a description of your
journey through
well let's call it first purgatory and
then maybe hell
i think you're probably right and by the
way the audiobook will be out soon and
i've just uh
we've added we've been adding sound
effects and ambience and atmosphere to
that to make it to make it really
feel like that hellish
journey you know so you're actually
there and present uh more so than just a
regular like me reading the audio book
and i've got a couple of great people
who've helped with that andrea romano
who's one nine nine nine time emmy award
winner
uh she voice directed it and actually
read as one of the psychologists at the
end of the book so um
hopefully uh hopefully we'll do some
good and you know the emails that have
been coming back
from you know i was asked early on by
you know how it is that the hollywood
you know marketing and publicity and the
publishers you know who's your target
demographic i said look if if if we can
get the suicide rates down if if my book
can get to one person that then they can
feel like they're not alone well that's
a big deal for people to know that
they're not alone
you know
they're not crazy
i've got i had a
military uh father who lost his legs in
afghanistan
two chores at tools of duty was served
with false allegations of domestic
violence papers
he came home homeless
hasn't seen his kids i think for six
years he's been representing himself in
family law and i think about that jordan
and it just
it it makes me we talk about being
punished for your virtues man whoa
you said it
you said it
you know
all right well mr ellis
looks good to see you on your feet and
through this piece of some degree
thank you
very much pleasure talking with you man
yeah you too man really keep up the
astonishing work
[Music]
you